will you do hungry-man form for us
really I love it so much
it's basically I wish this it came from
I was on stage and I was like well I I'm
a single guy and I eat a lot of and I
meant to say hungry man dinners but
actually said lonely man I was like oh
my god that's what hungry man dinners
are I was like okay what's the ad for
lonely man brand single man dinners and
just just a just a you know a cabin in
the woods with a guy by himself and a
beard looking out the window of a vision
of a future he'll never have with his
children and wife playing in the snow
they're not really there and there's a
faraway shot of the cabin and the theme
song kicks in no need to open the can
are you happy settle down the man and
then a far away shot in a single gunshot
so depressing loneliness its you're
funny what else you want to see oh man
uh last night you blogged about how loud
it was can I tell you that oh I'm over
at the Driscoll haunted keepin an eye
out yeah are you there
oh no I'm at the Hyatt because as long
as it's right on the gap right off the
strip don't stop mmm don't stop this
bunch of people outside my window I just
kept heard like oh it's a hundred people
it's six people that Keith
intermittently swing dancing just
spinning around each other I'm like not
just doing it's like screaming at
nothing and I'm like did they all just
inhale a mason jar of cocaine
like why would we ever slow down jr.
Morgan the weirdest thing where I want
to be like wanna come downstairs like a
robe like shut up come out in front of
my hotel like stop drunk is like look at
how much fun they're having
yeah people seems like to me oh I'm 15
floors up there solo windows not open at
all I'm just watching them like manic
ants and every other hand that goes like
no everybody walks around oh my god
and they're they keep chasing people
like you - I'm trying to get him to
swing - Hanson whatever
I wonder why my favorite moment this
guy's like you know 2/3 and then like
flipping her around no music there's no
music you know they're not playing
anything
no puts around and does the old it's one
of my favorite things and it's horrible
but the the swing dance mistake because
you know you over seen her know you'd
seen it weddings in like the late 90s
when swingers came out and it was just
become a drinking age and it's gonna be
like alright we around let's try
something tough I'm gonna throw you over
my back and it's like and WWE Oh Sylvia
oh my god
no and that man he just whipped he
whipped this woman around and she just
she went right into a door like but no
no and I was like ah like I'm not like
high high grades I was like no but she
was like II there's a moment and she's
like dude dude dude
came back right away there's no more
wholesome activity than just a bunch of
young kids just swing Mantha oh no no
not young kids now young kids more than
all of us I like that that person you
were joking about like a body slam yeah
guys oh you like to think that I guess
because 20 minutes late
20 years later that's the man from lowly
man oh it's social I have to go and he
killed his own belong by putting her
through a table yep
to the tune of jump jive oh he's Waylon